JAKE: He wrote the
high-performance browser
networking book
for O'Reilly, which
is also available for free
in the links on his website.
If the internet is
a series of tubes,
then this is one of the
world's greatest plumbers.
Hands together
for Ilya Grigorik.
[APPLAUSE]
ILYA GRIGORIK: All
right, thanks, Jake.
All right, so we're going
to talk a little bit
about optimizing network
performance and specifically
some of the things that we've
been doing on the Chrome team
for helping deliver better apps.
And I guess the first
thing that we should ask
is, does it matter, right?
What's the problem
we're trying to solve?
And Tony Gentilcore, who's
actually somewhere here
in the room, ran a
number of different tests
over the last couple
of months, where
he's been kind of deep
diving into where do we
spend our time.
Like when we try to
render a web page, what
are the bottlenecks today?
And he has a series
of these posts
on Blink-dev if you guys
are interested in kind
of low-level guts
of how Blink works
and in Chrome kind
of end to end.
But one test to me stood
out, in particular.
And this is a test where we took
the top 1 million Alexa sites
and just ran them
through Chrome and looked
at where do we spend our time?
Like in terms of the
actual main Blink thread,
where is the time going?
And the big takeaway here
is that, approximately 70%
of the time, we're
just basically idling
on the network, right?
That's that big chunk
right here in the blue.
And then after that, you have
all of your usual offenders,
things like, well, we've
got to get the JavaScript,
we've got to paint pixels,
and all the rest, do layouts.
So this should not
be surprising, right?
This is specifically
for the first page load.
There's a very
different profile,
of course, once
the page is loaded
and you're interacting
with the page.
That's a different problem.
But this, in part,
is one big problem
that we're trying to solve.
Like how do we make this blue
part smaller or just go faster?
So there's two takeaways
that you can take from this.
One is, page loads in
network are a problem, right?
That's 70% of loading
the page today.
But the good news is that if we
can do anything to the network
stack in terms of improving
that latency and improving
performance, it's going to have
a significant impact on how
we experience the web.
So even small fractional
wins in this space
will, in fact, have
huge performance impact.
So kind of with that in
mind, what I wanted to do
is actually take a look
at some of the things
that we've been working
on internally in Chrome.
This is kind of
looking under the hood.
This is not perhaps
something that you
would be, as a developer,
looking at APIs
or trying to figure
out how to optimize.
This is the kind of stuff
that Chrome does internally.
But we have a very dedicated
and awesome performance team
working on this stuff.
And I wanted to highlight
some of the wins
that we had over the last year
and also kind of essentially
so you know what
we're working on
and also highlight the
potential areas for improvement
in the future.
And after that,
we're going to look
at some of the new
additions, specifically,
kind of low-level
network plumbing
stuff that we support
in Chrome, so things
like SPDY, some notes about
QUIC, and other things.
And then finally we'll talk
about measurements, right?
Of course, performance
is the big theme
throughout this entire event.
And we want to make sure
that we give you the tools
to measure performance
in the best way possible.
You should be able to measure
anything you need in the stack.
So first, let's actually
do a quick survey.
This is going to be kind
of all over the map,
but I want to
highlight a few things.
First, in Chrome 26, we landed
the new asynchronous DNS
resolver, which is kind of
low-level plumbing stuff,
so we're no longer relying
on the operating system DNS
resolver.
We actually have our own.
Today, it's available on
Windows, Mac, and Chrome
OS, so this is
not yet on mobile.
Hopefully, it will be.
So why did we want to do this?
Well, first of all, it
gives us a lot more control.
We can do a lot
smarter strategies
for high resolve names
and other things.
And here's some
performance numbers
in terms of what we've seen
since we've landed M26.
It took us a couple of tries
to actually kind of get
the performance numbers
as good as they are.
But you can see that
there's significant wins
across the board.
And for things like
Chrome OS, we've
reduced the DNS resolution
time significantly, 36%.
And not only that,
but we're also
measuring the resolve
plus TCP connect.
And you can see that there
are wins across the board.
And of course, some of
these are platform specific.
Some platforms just
do a better job
of implementing their DNS
resolvers in the first place.
But the cool thing is
that we can actually now
kind of take control
now that we've
got the basic plumbing working.
We can take control
and do smarter things.
So, for example, we can
raise different resolutions
for IPv6 and IPv4.
We are now actually
doing adaptive retry,
so we actually remember
which DNS servers we've used.
So we can do a better job of
making these resolutions faster
in the future.
And this is definitely a
space for a lot of improvement
and also kind of subtle things
like providing better user
error pages, right?
Before you would just
get a failed timeout
from DNS resolution.
I mean, you just kind
of like, we give up.
We have no idea.
We can't give any useful
feedback to the user.
Now we can go
much, much further.
So that's pretty cool.
Moving on, in M27, we landed
this big and important
improvement, which is we
completely rewrote how
we schedule resources.
It's one thing for us
to get the HTML bytes.
We then discovered
the resources.
And then we need to figure
out how do we schedule them
efficiently on the wire,
like we care about JavaScript
before images and other things.
And the big change that we've
done in there, in M27, is we
replaced that scheduler.
And we also started focusing
on perceived performance.
So instead of just measuring
the page load time,
we started measuring
things like speed index.
So what kind of optimizations
we can do in Resource Scheduler
to improve speed index.
In fact, we've made decisions
where we've intentionally
chosen speed index over
page load time, or unload.
So there are changes
that have gone
in where we've regressed,
in some cases, on load time.
But we've improved
speed index, because we
think that perceived
performance, getting
useful pixels on the screen,
is a win for the user.
And one interesting
takeaway from this work
that was done in M27 was that
we realized that a lot of pages
were actually competing for
bandwidth unnecessarily.
So they were trying to
download too many things.
We've gotten so good at charting
our assets that it's actually
backfiring on a lot of sites.
So, in particular, one
big interesting change
that went in in that iteration
was that the new scheduler
would only download up
to 10 images in parallel.
So, for example, if you
have a gallery of images,
you have let's say 30
of them on the page,
and you sharded them
in 20 different ways,
we would not open more than
10 connections at once.
Because we found
that that actually
hurts performance in most cases.
So if you're developing
your site today,
Chrome will limit you
to 10 image downloads.
But in other browsers,
you'll still have no problem.
I'm not sure what exact
scheduling algorithms
they're using, but
perhaps something you
should consider on your site.
There is such thing as
oversharding your site.
Later in M28, speaking
of perceived performance,
we've also improved the SPDY
performance quite a bit.
So the change here is
actually pretty awesome
and pretty trivial
in that now that we
have control over the
Resource Scheduler
we said, look, if
you're using SPDY,
we have a much better way
to schedule resources, which
is we know the priority.
We can send that
priority to the server.
The server can do
the right thing.
So we won't delay any
resource scheduling
on the client, which is kind of
this like this fake latency--
not fake, unnecessary
latency that we're otherwise
introducing.
So if you're using SPDY,
this is a nice performance
win because it allows
us once again to get
those pixels visible
earlier on the screen.
So if you haven't
already, I definitely
encourage you to look
into playing with SPDY.
So if you're using Apache, you
can sell them on SPDY EngineX,
and other server are
supported as well.
And actually, we'll come back
to SPDY a little bit later.
In M30, there's been
yet more improvements
to the Resource Scheduler.
We keep improving
and iterating on all
of these different strategies.
One interesting kind of takeaway
that we had in this iteration
was that we actually
started distinguishing
between optimizing for the
popular sites versus sites
in the tail.
There's different
ways that sites
are constructed in terms of
kind of patterns that they use,
how they lay out the
resources, and all the rest.
And this iteration,
in particular,
actually helped
quite a bit in terms
of accelerating the
sites in the long tail.
And if you think about
a 10% improvement
in firing the
onload, this is just
like one Chrome m
revision, it's huge.
That's a 10% win in onload and
a 9% improvement in speed index.
So there's just faster
pixels on the screen.
So these are impressive numbers.
And I think what's most exciting
for me is if we look forward,
based on the work that we
have in the pipeline now,
and project it a little bit,
we see significant improvements
that we can still make
to these algorithms.
So right now, at least based on
the current code that we have,
you can expect more wins
rolling out to our users.
So this is great.
As far as I'm concerned,
this is free performance.
Like the apps,
it's the same apps,
they're just rendering
faster, because we're
doing a better job
of how we schedule
those resources in Chrome.
So that's pretty exciting.
Another huge win that's coming
and that's available on Android
today is what we're
calling the "simple Cache".
So one of the problems
that we realized
that we had on Android
and mobile phones,
in particular, is that in order
for us to dispatch a network
request, we actually had to do
a number of different context
switches.
Like we would go from the main
threads to an I/O thread to
we'd do another jump.
We would always do a check
on the file system, which
in itself can take
quite a bit of time.
And the idea behind Simple Cache
is to try to simplify that,
as the name implies,
to the extent
that we can, and ideally, avoid
any context switches ongoing
to disk.
So that should help
quite a bit in terms
of the actual performance
of the Simple Cache.
And here's some early numbers.
These look very, very good.
The blue line on the
bottom is the original,
and what you see
here is the latency.
So you kind of had this
like long tail distribution,
where basically every
request incurred
a minimum of several
milliseconds.
But then you had
this long tail, where
it wasn't atypical for a
request to take 50 milliseconds
before we could
even dispatch it.
Because we had to kind
of do a couple of thread
hops and then check
disk, or check
Flash, in this case, and
kind of bubble that back up.
With the new Simple
Cache, basically we
can just complete
it immediately,
most of the requests.
Every once in a while, we
still have some delays,
but this is the
type of line where
you want to see on all of
your performance charts.
And this is quite amazing
because once we have the Simple
Cache, based on
our measurements,
this has improved all
HTTP transfers, the speed
of these transfers,
in terms of the time
from the first
request byte that we
want to send to
completion by 10%, which,
if you think about
it, is massive, right?
And not only that,
but in M31 we're
seeing 7% page load
time improvement.
So this is simply eliminating
that extra latency
at the beginning of
each and every request.
And once again, there's
more work going into M32,
and we hope that we can
improve this even further.
So this is huge,
and this will be
an awesome win for
mobile browsers.
And then finally, one of
the last things that we've
started iterating towards
the end of the year here,
and something that I'm
really, really excited about,
is focusing on improving the
speculative optimizations
that we already do in Chrome.
We do a lot of speculative
optimization as it is today.
But now we're also looking
at how do we refine these?
How do we expose the
right primitives,
and how do we make
better use of them?
One example is something
like prefetch, right?
So if you're familiar
with a link rel=prefetch,
what it allows you
to say is, hey,
I will need this resource
perhaps on the next page.
That could be an
HTML page, that could
be a CSS file, an
image, what have you.
Please fetch this
for me, such that I
don't have to fetch that,
or I can just fetch it out
of the cache when the
user initiates that load.
One of the gotchas there
was, if that request did not
complete in time for
the next navigation,
it would get canceled.
So you kind of incur
the double download
and it just didn't make sense.
So, for example, we have
this new patch that's in.
It's not available in Canary
yet, but it's coming soon,
called detachable prefetch,
which will actually
keep the prefetch alive even
as you navigate away, such
that you can still make
use of that resource
once you get to
your destination.
So that's pretty awesome.
And this will also apply to
other things like prerenders
and other types of improvements.
So this is pretty cool.
And this is how,
basically, it looks.
Chrome allows you to actually
dynamically create these hints.
So, for example, if, let's
say, the user initiates
some sort of an action, like
they click on the Checkout
button or they click
on Add To Cart button
and you know that they're going
to go to the checkout page,
at that moment you can actually
inject one of these link
elements and say,
hey, I would like
you to prefetch that asset
for me, because now I
know I will need it.
And vice versa, you can
actually delete this element out
of the DOM, and we will
cancel the prefetch as well.
So you can dynamically
script how and basically
drive Chrome to do these
prefetches for you.
So this is pretty cool stuff.
And I think this
is a place where
we can do a lot more
in the future as well.
So that's a little bit about
kind of the low-level guts
and improvements in Chrome.
Now let's take a look
at some of the protocols
that we've been working on.
So back in 2009, roughly,
actually four years ago
almost on the dot,
we announced our work
on SPDY or initial
efforts around SPDY.
And since then we've gone,
I think, quite a long way.
We've had several iterations
of the protocol itself, so v2,
v3, 3.1.
Now we're working on Version 4.
And that actually
became the foundation
of HTTP 2.0, which
is pretty exciting.
And HTTP 2.0 work in itself
is progressing quite rapidly,
and I'm really
excited about that.
So today we actually have
both SPDY and HTTP 2.0 support
in Chrome, although HTTP
2.0 is under a flag.
But it is there.
It's something that
we're iterating on.
And then once HTTP 2.0-- I
know this is a common question.
Once HTTP 2.0 is marked
as ready, as a standard,
we'll just switch
over to HTTP 2.0.
So think of SPDY as kind of like
an experimental ground for us
to try different ideas
and feed them back
into the HTTP 2.0 spec, right?
So like it'd be great
if we had this feature.
Let's go and try and
implement that feature.
We try it, and we
discover the rough edges,
and then we kind of feed
that back into HTTP 2.0.
So earlier in the
year, we actually
deployed SPDY 3.1 across
all of our Google servers
and, of course, added
support in Chrome.
Firefox also supports SPDY v3.1.
And here's some numbers.
We've never released
this before,
but these are the
performance numbers
that we see for SPDY across some
of the major Google properties,
and these are consistent across
all the different Google sites.
So you're kind of looking at
the right order of magnitude,
anywhere between 20 to 40 to
50% improvement in latency as
compared to HTTPS.
And in some cases,
we're actually-- so even
despite the fact that we have
these extra handshake round
trips and all the rest
in CLS, oftentimes
we actually end up going
faster than just vanilla HTTP
as well, which is,
of course, the point
of this whole exercise
to begin with.
So this is really exciting.
And I guess the important bit
here is also that not only is
it helping the median, which is,
of course, what we like to see,
but it's also consistently
helping all of our users,
the ones on fast connections,
and especially so for the ones
that are ion the slow
connections or the ones
with the high RTT times,
which is especially
relevant for things like mobile,
where RTTs are definitely
higher.
So this is really exciting.
This is very promising.
And I hope that this will help
kind of drive the HTTP 2.0
adoption as well.
So if you haven't
looked at SPDY,
I definitely encourage
you to do so.
There are modules for
virtually every popular server
out there today that
you can enable and just
play with, enable
it on your site.
And there's also
commercial support for it
as well, so F5, Akamai,
and others support SPDY.
So that's pretty cool.
And as I mentioned, we
also do have HTTP 2.0.
If you're curious, if
you want to play with it,
we do have HTTP 2.0
support under a flag.
So you can actually
enable that and then
run it against
your local server.
I think the only big
public site that supports
HTTP 2.0 today is twitter.com.
So in theory, you
can test it on that.
But there are also
open source servers
that speak HTTP 2.0 today
that you can play with.
So SPDY is kind of a production
version, if you will.
HTTP 2.0 is coming soon
and hopefully, fingers
crossed, sometime in 2014.
So that's SPDY.
You may have caught the
wind of some other protocol
that we started working on
earlier in the year, which
is QUIC, which is Quick
UDP Internet Connections.
And the idea here is
actually to kind of take
what we've done with SPDY
and go one step beyond.
And this was actually our intent
right at the very beginning
when we started
thinking of SPDY.
But it was just
too much of a leap
to change both the protocol,
kind of the application
protocol, and the
transfer protocols.
So we kind of decoupled those,
and QUIC is basically that.
We're trying to go one
step further and say, well,
could we build a
better transport
for HTTP traffic,
period, on top of UDP?
Could we experiment
with new ideas?
The core premise of this stuff
is it's all about latency.
We're trying to eliminate
latency everywhere we can.
So can we eliminate
extra round trips
to establish the secure tunnel?
Can we do better
congestion control?
What if we do packet pacing?
What if we do forward
error correction?
What can we do to
innovate in the space
to help reduce the page
load times on the web?
And there's a lot of
interesting ideas.
If you guys are curious
about this kind of stuff,
we posted our design docs.
And it's a very long doc.
I encourage you to read
it and give us feedback.
We have a Google group for that.
And this question comes
up quite frequently,
which is, like,
what's the point?
What are you trying to do here?
And the answer is very simple.
We just want to make faster
internet for everybody to use.
And there are two ways
that this will happen.
One is we end up building
a really awesome protocol
that everybody loves
and we take it to ITF.
And just like with
HTTP 2.0 and SPDY,
we work with the community and
kind of make that the standard.
That's plausible and
maybe that will happen.
The alternative route is, we
just experiment with QUIC.
We experiment with
different ideas.
And those ideas get adopted,
the good ones get adopted
into existing protocol
stacks, like TCP and TLS.
And actually we're
already seeing
some of that, where based on our
experience with the encryption
stuff in QUIC, the TLS
working group is looking
at improvements
in terms of can we
eliminate some
extra round trips.
So in either case, the point
is, no matter which one of these
happens, the users will win.
We'll get faster internet.
And that's our intent with QUIC.
So that's pretty awesome.
We don't have any benchmarks
for it as of today.
We're still at a point where we
want to make sure that it works
and it works correctly
before we start
optimizing kind of all
the edges around it.
But you can actually
play with QUIC today.
We have it deployed
on Google servers,
and you can also enable it.
If you go into Chrome flags,
you can flip QUIC Support.
And then you can, for
example, access YouTube,
and you'll get served--
youtube.com or other Google
service-- over UDP, over QUIC.
And if you're curious, you can
dive into Chrome net internals
and kind of look at
the actual protocol
and all this other stuff.
So if you're into kind of
low-level networking protocols,
definitely a thing you want
to check out and play with.
There's lots of interesting
ideas in the protocol.
All right, shifting gears.
Linus mentioned Chrome
data compression.
This is something that we
launched early in the year.
As you heard, it provides
roughly 50% data savings.
That's kind of the average
number for a lot of users.
It turns out there's a lot
of poorly compressed content
on the web.
People still forget to
gzip their content, which
is one of the optimizations
that we apply for text, like
[INAUDIBLE].
And we also convert
all the images
to IP, which provides
a significant savings.
So this is a big benefit
to a lot of users.
But one thing that
Linus didn't mention
is that there are other
secondary benefits to that.
Because we run over SPDY,
so between your phone
and the Google server, it's
actually a SPDY connection.
It's an encrypted connection.
So I actually use Chrome
data compression in part
for the data compression
part, but also
partially to secure my browsing.
Because when I enable this,
the secure traffic, if you're
connecting to your bank,
for example, an HTTPS site,
it will go directly to the site.
So that traffic is encrypted.
But if you're trying to connect
to some unencrypted site,
it'll just flow basically
as it is on the wire.
With Chrome data
compression, that
goes through a secure tunnel,
so even if you're on a Starbucks
Wi-Fi or whatever,
some unencrypted Wi-Fi
and you're browsing around,
all of your data is encrypted.
So that's really nice.
And maybe one important thing
to highlight with Chrome data
compression is, it is still
the full fidelity HTML5 web
experience, right?
We're not doing anything
to modify your site.
We're not trying to
render it on the server.
Like you have all of the
flexibility of JavaScript, CSS,
and all the rest on your phone.
That's where the
code gets executed.
So we're just modifying and
optimizing some of the assets
as they get delivered.
Some common questions that I get
about Chrome data compression,
something you should know, is
this is going through a proxy.
So if you're developing
a site where you're
relying on GoIP
functionality to customize
the location to the user or
maybe serve relevant ads,
you should be looking
for the X Forwarded
For header, which
is the IP address
of the client as forwarded
by the Chrome data proxy.
And similarly, if
for whatever reason
you absolutely want to make
sure that we don't do anything
to your content,
you can actually
opt out on a per-resource basis.
If you add a no
transform header,
it basically tells the
Chrome data proxy to just
be hands off with that resource.
So we won't
reoptimize that image,
or we won't recompress
that text, or other things.
So these are standard
kind of proxy directives.
Chrome data compression
proxies supports it.
So, just an FYI.
Shifting gears, web sockets.
This is really, really exciting.
Do we have any web socket
developers in the room?
Yes.
Awesome.
So web socket
compression is going
to be live in M32, which
is a long overdue feature.
One of the gotchas
with web sockets
was that you could
transfer binary in text,
but text would always
go as uncompressed
in both directions.
Now that we have
the spec up to date
and we already have
the code in Chrome,
you can actually negotiate
the deflate compression
to apply in both directions,
and the server can selectively
compress any given frame.
And the client, as
of today, Chrome
will compress every
single frame going out
from your mobile device or
from your desktop device.
And I'm not going to
go into details here,
but we also, actually,
the spec provides
a number of different
parameters to customize
how the compression
will be done.
For example, the size of the
sliding window, so essentially
you can control the
resources used on your server
and on your client,
plus some other flags.
So this is really,
really exciting,
because this has definitely been
a sore point for web sockets.
We heard about WebRTC
and DataChannel.
The way I think
about DataChannel
is basically WebSocket,
but over UDP and P2P.
So we can communicate
directly between devices.
We don't have to go through
an intermediary like a server.
And DataChannel and M31
has now officially switched
to SCTP protocol.
So previously we were
using RTP data channels,
and that was the reason for
some of the incompatibilities
with some of the other vendors.
But as of M31, SCTP
is the default,
and we will aggressively remove
support for RTP data channels.
So if you're using
data channels today,
this is something
you want to revisit.
And if you're not familiar
with data channels,
I encourage you to
check out the links.
I'll post the slides
later for how this works
and why this is awesome.
Because it allows you
to define things like,
fire-and-forget semantics,
don't retransmit.
So it's a really nice transport
for doing low-latency data
exchange.
And then finally, let's talk
about measurements, right?
So there's a lot of kind
of protocol improvements
that are going on.
But as we know, we need to
be able to measure things
in order to improve them.
So, of course, we're all
familiar with navigation
timing, or I hope we are.
Most of the people
here I expect would be.
You can get detailed
low-level stats
about how long did
each connection take
in terms of DNS times, TCP
time, and all the other things.
You can throw that into your
analytics solution here.
I'm showing you Google
Analytics, which
allows you to segment
this data to say, well,
I want to look at my mobile
users versus desktop.
You can segment it
by any other variable
you define, like has a user
clicked the Checkout button,
or have they
registered, et cetera.
This is all great.
One gotcha with this is this is
only for the main page, right?
What about the other 85
resources or 100 resources
that you have on your page?
How are those performing?
Well in Chrome, we have support
for resource timing, which
gives you that same level of
access to all of the network
metadata, or
timestamps, I should
say, on a per-resource basis.
So you can see here
that you can actually
query for a specific
resource, like your JavaScript
file that you're loading.
Maybe you're loading
it from CDN and you're
wondering how well
is my CDN performing.
You can get your
real user measurement
data for that specific
resource and then look up
the time for DNS, TCP connect
time, total transfer time,
et cetera.
The only thing that
you need to be aware of
is that the resource has to
manually opt in and allow
the data to be
gathered to begin with.
This is done for privacy
reasons to make sure
that somebody can't just iterate
or recache and figure out
where you've been in the
past, or something like it.
So for your own resources
you need to add this header.
And then if you're using
third party resources,
if that origin is already
not providing this header,
then you should
ask them to do so.
Because here's one example where
I have a web font on my site.
Web fonts delay when
the tech gets painted.
So the question is,
how is-- in this case,
this is a Google CDN.
How is Google CDN
performing in terms
of serving the actual font?
Is it hurting my users?
Well, now I can actually grab
that data from Resource Timing,
just as I showed you
a few slides ago.
And we can just pump that
into Google Analytics.
Here you can see that I'm
tracking the DNS, TCP,
and transfer times.
And it turns out
that the fonts coming
from Google CDN, at
least for my site,
are being loaded in this case
within 150 milliseconds, which
to me was an acceptable time.
And that was fine for me.
But you can now think about
using this sort of data
to define third party SLAs.
You rely on third party
widgets you can say, well,
your widgets must load in x
amount of time, et cetera.
You can actually track
this with Resource Timing,
which is pretty awesome.
So as a quick recap, we
covered a lot of ground.
There's a new DNS
Resolver in Chrome,
which is double-digit
performance improvement
and actual DNS resolutions.
And the new scheduler
is definitely
something we're
really excited about.
We've already seen huge
improvements there,
10% and 20% improvement
in the actual speed
index and page load times.
The Simple Cache stuff
is a huge win on mobile,
and I'm really excited
to have that out there.
And then moving
forward, I'm hoping
that we can make the preresolve
and prefetch and the prerender
stuff much, much smarter.
And you saw the
SPDY wins, right?
So all of these things
are incremental, 10% here,
20% there.
Before you know
it, you're actually
saving hundreds of milliseconds,
and sometimes seconds,
for the user, which
is a huge win.
And some of these things you
guys need to optimize for.
These are the things where
you need to install SPDY,
you need to configure
SPDY, you need
to make sure that your stacks
are configured correctly.
And in other cases,
it's just also doing
a better job of scheduling
this kind of stuff.
And then finally, if
you haven't already,
I definitely
encourage you to look
at things like Nav Timing, User
Timing, and Resource Timing.
So I talked about
Resource Timing.
User Timing allows you to
measure any chunk of code
and just get high-resolution
time stamps for this
is when I started, this is when
I ended, and beacon that back
to your server.
So all of these things
are supported in Chrome.
And what you can measure,
you can optimize.
So with that, I'll leave
you the link to the slides.
Thank you.